retail today is undergoing significant
transformation driven by increased
customer expectations competition and
cost inflation
to compete retailers need to manage
operations across every channel digital
and physical in particular the store
which today must balance customer
service inventory management e-commerce
order fulfillment transactions risk and
loss preventions maintenance and much
more
hi i'm oksana deporte a cloud pack
platform product manager
with ibm cloud packs with brought
together a series of hybrid cloud
technologies for integration data and ai
in a unified platform that seamlessly
orchestrates the dynamics of the modern
retailer enabling better experiences for
customers and similar ways of working
let's consider a typical retailer with
hundreds of stores thousands of store
associates tens of thousands of products
and millions of customers
each day in real time deliveries are
made shelves are filled stock is managed
e-commerce order fulfilled and customers
are served
many of the typical daily processes are
planned or scheduled however others are
dynamic and require action in real time
let's take a closer look at what happens
when a customer goes to a retailer's
website and chooses to buy online and
pick up in store
while this is captured on the digital
channel it now creates a new activity
for the store to manage
here the customer uses watson assistant
in ibm cloud pack for data to amend
their order
in parallel the store associate is
notified of the in-store pickup
and how this fits in with other store
activities
when the customer arrives she confirms
pickup and the store associate is
advised of her arrival
at every stage the system automatically
coordinates and prioritizes activities
for the store associate who is just a
click away from the applications he
needs to complete the activity
and the customer is immediately informed
when her items are ready for collection
store teams can see what is being
managed in real time
allowing them to continuously identify
opportunities for improvement
let's look at what's enabling this
intelligent retail
orchestration first there is the
retailer's existing environment
containing many of their competitive
differentiators like erp
commerce systems or data
none of this changes
ibm cloud pack for integration enables
the flow of information from multiple
systems for a unified platform
capability
here we are capturing events securely in
real time through event streaming
capability driving fully automated
intelligent workflows across the retail
operation
now we see ibm cloudback for data
triggering the relevant ai models to
optimize operations and experiences
but this is not a black box
all of the ai driven orchestration is
visible and explainable
here we see the models creating priority
events
behind the scenes watson knowledge
catalog normalizes data using an open
standards industry schema which
facilitates the building and training of
ai models using watson studio
watson machine learning
decision optimization and data
virtualization connecting to all
operational master and external data
ibm cloudback for data makes the
development and deployment of models
easy
ensuring they perform efficiently right
task right associate right time
for the best customer
experience
watson open scale tracks and measures
outcomes from ai models to ensure they
remain fair explainable and compliant
detecting and correcting model drift
while the model is in production
now the customer can easily amend her
order using watson assistant
automatically creating new activities
for the store through integration with
critical systems giving the customer a
seamless experience
because all of this runs on red hat
openshift it can be deployed anywhere on
any cloud or on premises with a common
interface for devops and administration
as you've seen we've used ibm cloud
packs to enable a configurable unified
platform to orchestrate retail
operations
so instead of relying on shared
documentation to establish standards
retailers can now codify their retail
operating model
ensuring every store is orchestrated to
the same high standards
both in performance and experience
thank you for watching if you have any
questions please drop us a line below if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future please like and subscribe and
don't forget if you want to learn more
about ibm cloud packs please check out
the links below